thailand is shutting down construction
sites
and indoor dining as well as banning
gatherings of more than 20 people
the latest restrictions to address new
outbreaks of kovid 19.
grim news for a tourist hub at the start
of the summer season
i need to cook i don't make any profit
nowadays
at best i break even but i can't stop
selling food
it's my livelihood i can't rely on the
government's help
every day can i we have to save
ourselves it doesn't make any sense to
ask for helping hands now
supahrak has been cooking noodles in
bangkok's chinatown
for most of her life her shop has been
open for 49 years
for millions just like her the pandemic
has meant it's a struggle just to make a
living
indonesia set a new record for daily
cases on sunday
with a total of more than 21 thousand
hospitals in the capital jakarta are
overflowing with patients
it is the hardest hit southeast asian
nation with more than fifty seven
thousand deaths but the real figure is
believed to be even higher
during an emergency meeting an
australian health official warned
the situation there is the worst it's
been since the first wave of the
pandemic
cities across the country are going back
into lockdown
we really face the most serious crisis
in the
covert pandemic since the early days
in february march last year
it's made the worst because this was a
largely avoidable
and foreseeable crisis but thanks to the
uh very poor procurement and roll out of
the vaccines we don't have that
strength to uh to respond to the
situation that's emerging
in fiji there's been a sharp rise in
cases this month even relatively
isolated island nations
have been unable to avoid the pandemic
the rise of cases in fiji is definitely
a wake-up call for pacific nations who
absolutely
can prevent a first wave from reaching
their shores
it is not an inevitability that we will
see covert taking over in the pacific
people are well coordinated governments
and humanitarian organizations are
working together
they are learning lessons from across
the pacific and across the globe
but for many they continue to be
difficult lessons
it's a lonely time man straight forward
like
because you you know you can't see your
families
you can't you don't see your friends you
can't
like yeah we can talk through social
media but
now we're just longing for the contact
that like because as us is specifically
us as fijians we always that can you
know touch
we want some despite new variants aid
groups say getting jabs in arms
is still the only way to slow down the
pandemic which continues
to hurt people and economies around the
world
zain basravi al-jazeera